So, in this particular slide we have the results of our analysis model.
There were classes corresponding to our three major elements and
then there were associations among the elements.
There was one binary association having to do with displaying the contents.
And there were other ternary or three part associations that indicated how
the misc, how the three components worked together to make sure that the scroll
bar affected the lines on the screen, and that the scroll bar handle and
the position of the scroll bar handle were all right.
Now, in analysis, UML supports the idea of associations.
In design, there are no associations,
in programming languages there are no associations.
Instead there are in UML what are called dependencies.
So part of our process here will be going and taking these associations and
translating them into dependencies.
Also, the comments which describe the guarantees in the previous,
picture have been translated into or, they, they,
they have the OCL constraints which we developed during the analysis phase.